eine kurve station in gaza amid novitas
mutter wurde vor drei wochen hier
eingeliefert die 70-jährige ist
ungeimpft ihr zustand kritisch die frau
ging mit dem tod der sohn sitzt täglich
an ihrem bett
singt immer wieder ab auf 54 58
der arzt sagte sie wird nicht mehr lange
leben
der rettungs die familie zu versammeln
[Musik]
der arzt dass es doktor alack hat der
hat im august 2020 den ersten kurve
patienten in gaza versorgt damals waren
die stationen voll
notunterkünfte im klinik garten sollen
den notstand dieses mal verhindern noch
sind die zahlen niedrig aber die vierte
welle kündigt sich an omikron ist in
diesen tagen auch in gaza angekommen mit
nach unten wir haben große angst vor
dieser welle und der neuen variante wir
fürchten dass wir nicht standhalten
können
neben schutzausrüstung fehle es vor
allem an personal so ist die tägliche
visite chefsache
danke sagten danke allah sei mit ihm
so wird patienten sind hier nicht
isoliert aber sorge vor der infektion
hat amino wieder keiner anders als die
mutter sei er sogar doppelt geimpft
immer wenn ich ins zimmer gehe
desinfiziere ich meine hände ich habe
keine angst
und alle paar stunden wischen sie den
boden
sie tun ihr bestes
coruna sei für viele hier nicht das
dringendste problem der gazastreifen
wird kontrolliert von der
radikalislamischen hamas die
arbeitslosigkeit liegt bei 50% jeder
zweite einwohner lebt unter der
armutsgrenze
auch die familie von armin wieder kämpft
mit der wirtschaftlichen not
der einzige verdienst ein stall für esel
der bringt der großfamilie 70 schekel
also knapp 20 euro die woche dazu der
ganze regen seit dem krieg mit israel im
mai habe das haus von armin risse
bekommen von den ganzen detonationen nun
sei es auch noch kalt und nass in der
ohnehin leeren küche
ich kaufe die tomaten grünen und nicht
reif und ich kaufe sie am ende des tages
wenn der verkäufer alles verkauft hat
denn dann ist das billiger
zu 15 leben sie in dem haus das armin
vor 20 jahren gebaut hat als er noch
arbeiter war in israel
die vier erwachsenen söhne von armin
sind wie er seit monaten arbeitslos
ebenso wie die nerven
wir sind am nullpunkt
unsere regierung hat uns zerstört ich
bin ein großer und starker junger mann
aber ich finde keine arbeit wir haben
hunger wir wollen doch unbedingt leben
aber unsere regierung hat uns
massakriert
meine söhne würden sofort auswandern im
flüchtlingsboot über das meer auch wenn
das tödlich sein kann aber besser so als
hier zu enden
auch armin würde sofort auswandern wären
da nicht seine eltern seien ungeimpfte
vater liegt seit wochen husten dem bett
aber ins krankenhaus villa nicht denn er
hat seine ganz eigene erklärung wie das
mit corona so läuft
corona kommt von gott von oben ich hoffe
dass sich die menschen lieben und gott
uns ein bald wieder gesundheit und
erfolg schenkt
[Musik]
großer armut gepaart mit religiöser
überzeugung der gazastreifen ist geprägt
vom sunnitischen islam und auch wenn
stadt hamm to versucht seine gläubigen
von der impfung zu überzeugen er hat
seine erzählung gefunden wie umgehen mit
den vielen corona toten
wir betrachten die kurve toten nicht als
minderwertig sondern für uns sind sie
mehr türen
gott hat sie auserwählt es ist ein ehren
tod im schatten dieser pandemie
corona tote als märtyrer der glaube
markt trost schenken in einer region die
auf die katastrophe zu rollt sollte sich
omikron hier mit derselben wucht
verbreiten wie in der welt nur omikron
stoppen das kann auch der glaube nicht
und die impfquote ist bisher niedrig
500.000 impfungen bei 2,2 millionen
einwohnern
nein ich habe mich nicht impfen lassen
weil ich angst hatte es wurde gesagt das
macht fieber und man hat nebenwirkungen
nach der impfung mit dem russischen
impfstoff kam die leute müde auf die
straße erst nach drei tagen waren sie
wieder normal deshalb habe ich das nicht
genommen
auch amys eltern hatten sich gegen die
impfung entschieden nun fordert das
virus seine opfer tage nach unserem dreh
meldet sich armin noch mal bei uns die
mutter sei gestorben als habe sie zu
sich geholt